the Shonan Jonah has been one of the
cornerstones of animates this man
realized the idea of one spunky muscled
dude punching another spunky must we do
to be a form of entertainment and has
shaped many of our fandoms in anime
Dragon Ball Z the definitive shown in
title that defines many of our
childhoods that remains to this day
the big three powerhouse shows that led
the charge and unlikely the reasons many
of you are anime fans now ferry failed
to tail a slightly smaller hit than the
three powerhouses which I can
objectively say after watching it was
definitely time spent innovation is not
something we normally praise in the
genre as a standard form that has been
seen many many many times and that's
fine we all know what we're getting into
at this point so even if the series
doesn't have many original ideas it's
kind of hard to really really [ __ ] up as
long as you know what you're doing oh
hey there black clover nice of you to
join us here why don't you take a seat
right there next to here I can oh this
season black clover has definitely
become everyone's new favorite punching
bag so as your friendly neighborhood
shown in trash [ __ ] boy of course I
would take it upon myself to investigate
the hate behind the show as to what it
is that could have possibly riled people
up so much this was meant to be the new
king of Shonen at least it was according
to crunch heroes marketing department as
with this rise to become one of the top
new manga currently running and shown
and jump a lot of eggs were put in this
basket for its become the new golden
goose of anime and with this proverbial
hype and the fact that you had to come
on stage following my hair academia is
rise to fame the set up was therefore a
huge disappointment which black clover
excitedly rattles you like the loud
special child that it was there was this
moment when I was watching a spunky
spiky haired hard-working protagonist
who has no magic powers whatsoever was a
naturally talented brooding rival who he
may or may not be fiercely bumming
behind the shed find out that he in fact
possesses a special power which he and
only he can we Ord allowing him to
pursue his dreams of being the wizard
king and the very best that no one ever
was that it slowly dawned on me that I
might have seen this somewhere before
but where I pondered and while wracking
my memories I concluded that perhaps it
was that one show called literally every
shown in battle anime created ever it
wasn't that the premise was reminiscent
of
chose this other series unashamedly
pulls from the list of every generic
shown in cliche you can think of that
can be interchanged from any other
series you have your edgy rival
loudmouth kids screaming about how he
wants to be king of the Pirates in the
hidden leaf village the captains of the
gotei 13 the guild of outcast mages and
in a world where most people get the
three leaf clover and you know is hailed
as a genius for having the four leaf
clover aster of course gets the
legendary power of the five tailed devil
fruits overpowered ability cancelling
ability check tinder a love interest
check and gold star you may be wondering
how I can be criticizing the abundant
use of generic shown and tropes when for
the past year I've been easing off my
stiffy and how am I here academia revels
in these same tropes without doing
anything entirely new and so that's I
say that black clover feels like it's
lacking something very important behind
it the heart well shows like hunter well
shows like hunter hunter JoJo's in one
punch man really pushing the boundary of
leftover originality in the genre I
would say that most things that can be
done have been done and I'm fine with
that because that means we are more
focused on the execution but here there
seems to be no rhyme or reason as to why
there's such a cesspool of uninspired
cliches which is a subtle but important
difference in the titles that draws from
for example in the ruto established
right at the beginning that the reason
he was allowed brash annoying [ __ ] was
because it was his way of getting
attention to himself after being outcast
his entire life and it was because of
this that it was so satisfying to see
him slowly mature and gain acceptance
from the people around him on the flip
side us this reasoning for being a loud
annoying [ __ ] seems to me because kids
hero ARCA Totoro Keys rivalry with Deku
stems from his upbringing causing his
desire to prove he is far beyond Deku
who is reminiscent of all might the
cause of his abusive childhood while you
know strong sense of scene aster as his
personal rival stems from seeing that he
got there as a kid that's like his
special ability
my point is that all these cliche
elements that are present seems to be
there simply because they are marketable
and popular and for no other reason
other than that it feels disingenuous as
it doesn't seem like any thought have
been put into why or how they define our
characters and their relationships and
the world around them
in fact initial world building bores
dancer characters periodically drawing
us close so they can subtly remind us
they are there because on the surface
these traces stood out in popular shown
in job titles individually we've mostly
just shot these things up - hey is just
shown and just let Shonen be Shonen but
put together and the show feels like it
was made by a committee of people
marking off a checklist from there how
to write the Shonan battle series for
dummies book and while these problems
stems from the actual start of the manga
it doesn't seem like a great adaptation
either as I wouldn't be able to get
through a black clover video without
mentioning asters chalk board grating
high-pitched screeching ear bleed
inducing screaming that just makes you
want to go let's use our indoor voice
while I am reluctant to say that if you
get used to his voice the experience as
a whole gets better as such a sentence
is akin to telling someone getting
stabbed repeatedly in the testicles
isn't so bad once the adrenaline kicks
in to mask the organising pain and I
will say that enduring six episodes now
on the screaming it's still one of the
few shows I can at least recommend a job
without getting lynched for it I would
say reading the manga made my experience
better but his streams had permeated my
conscience so deeply that I was still
hearing it in my head as I was reading
like a growing tumor that was killing me
from the inside as it stands is just an
unnecessary barrier to the anime which
is only a problem exclusive to the anime
but jeguk i hear you shouting in
disbelief surely you don't mean to say
that the studio that gave us such
perfect anime adaptations as edgy
sparkly vampire zombies makes boy walk
for 20 hours could be handling the show
badly
and well I'm sorry to break it to you
kids for Studio parrots are back at it
again this time reintroducing us to a
concept I have very happily not had to
talk about for a very long time filler
filler for you newer anime fans you
didn't have to sit through such
masterpieces as Naruto shadow clones
going on strike for there on sites
the water conditions is normally anime
original content which can take the form
of scenes episodes or entire [ __ ]
seasons that don't actually progress the
plot in any way and fill up the time now
if you're a new anime fan and this is
the first you're hearing about this then
you may be thinking wow that sounds like
an awful idea they're stupidly annoying
to have to sit through and endure just
to watch a show and but there was a
point to it which was to allow the manga
to get ahead before the anime caught up
to it as a general rule of thumb would
have two or three chapters being adapted
per anime episode in the modern era of
seasonal anime though this concept has
been mostly phased out which shows our
most putting our new seasons once a year
giving a very defined gap for the manga
to get ahead with new material without
the anime needing to fear of catching up
which I'm very grateful for new weights
shown in like hiraoka shokugeki and high
q-- have benefited from this greatly as
all the material animated has been
top-notch without any weird pacing
issues that Shonen used to be known for
so it absolutely baffles me why so much
filler has been added to the first few
episodes of black clover when there is
no reason to currently the first six
episodes cover four chapters which if
you've studied maths in school you'd be
able to figure out that that's on
average less than one chapter per anime
episode it's not even good filler three
minutes of recap and added at the start
of every episode and the rest of the
padded runtime is just filled with more
of a stir screeching voice it's as
though the studio were prepping for the
anime to catch up to the manga at
Episode one giving us a blisteringly
slow pace and the worst thing is that
unlike the og filler episodes and arcs
which can at least be skips the problem
of these episodes is that they are just
really slowly paced and the reason I
bring up all these criticisms is because
black clover shouldn't be this bad I'm
sorry it shouldn't be this bad
I read ahead in the manga ready to just
revel in the worst that Shonen Jump has
to offer and to my surprise it actually
wasn't that bad in fact there comes a
point when I would say that it becomes
kind of good there are definitely more
clearly defined strengths that the
series holds the fun really comes from
the introduction of the big ensemble
cast and the variety there is not only
with the cast members but the special
magic that everyone is capable of
combine this with the pacing which first
Shonen is blisteringly fast which is a
good thing in my opinion because Shonen
as a whole is normally paced slower than
your average show even without filler
because of how much time they have to
work with but there always feels like
there is progression in every single
chapter of black clover which is a
rarity for this genre while it is still
nothing groundbreaking the series is
just bundles of fun and it has its
moments so I certainly see it gaining a
fair bit of popularity despite its
seemingly trying it's damned hardest to
put viewers off early it's just a
shounen for pure shown and lovers and
there's enough here that I feel could be
very worth revisiting when and if the
anime gets these points because as it
stands black clover is the perfect case
study of how not to start a show both in
the introduction to a premise and the
execution of adapting the manga as an
adaptation it feels like a dated piece
of work but despite all this somehow I
just can't find myself completely hating
it it has this weird phenomenon where I
can spend an entire episode complaining
about how badly the show is executed and
how I lose a bit of my soul at a time
here asked the screen I need to find
myself clicking on that next episode
button anyway because there was that
really cool bit of animation or they
stopped before an event where I just
want to see what happens next
another time I wasn't sure if I was just
suffering from Stockholm Syndrome or if
there was something else actually there
is black clover the new king of Shonen
[ __ ] no but what I can say is that it
has the potential to be a very popular
show if the rest of the series is
handled decently I very much doubt this
will be the last time I talk about it as
I predict it will be one of those shows
that splits the anime community faster
than Moses parted the Red Sea but at
this current point it's just taking baby
steps and
literally the first thing he needs to do
is stop [ __ ]
yeah hey guys hope you enjoyed the video
thank you very much this month to Ella
for Robert Hahn Borg K must live basil
Lee Watts and everyone else a patron for
helping to support me for this month and
making this video possible a quick
update if you still want a chance to win
a ram figure or more importantly an
exclusive REM and ram trash bin you have
one day left to buy any volume of the
red light novel or manga from book
walker and if you use coupon code giga
that means you only need to spend less
than $2 to do so
links in the description anyway that's
it for me sorry you didn't get to see my
lovely face today but I didn't get time
to film this in live-action but I've
been gigging and I'll see you all next
time